every country in the west is now not
reproducing
instead we are focused on how do we
basically live out our last days as a
civilization in comfort and one of the
ways that we live our days as a
civilization and comfort is by lying to
ourselves about fulfillment being found
not in building
but in being
right fulfillment is not is not found in
in having a mission
or promulgating good values fulfillments
is found in naval gazing which is why
the state department
has now decided it's very important that
we issue the first third gender passport
for non-binary intersex and gender
non-conforming americans now you might
think to yourself wait a second
it is one thing for you to write on a
college essay that you are non-gender
conforming or that you are non-gender
binary or some nonsense
right it's one thing to write that in in
your in your little facebook profile
it's another thing for a governmental
document which specifically designated
in order to help determine who you are
to have you put that because that's a
subjective metric right it's like saying
i've it's like
putting on your passport that you're a
bon jovi fan like there's no way to tell
whether that's true or not
nor is it relevant your interior
feelings have no relevance to the
question of how the government ought to
identify you for purposes of knowing who
the hell's in the country
but the state department now feels it's
very important for you to look at your
passport and feel that your passport
reflects your innermost feelings or
society that now treasures the inner
subjectivity of feelings over
the identification within reality
according to abc news four months after
announcing it would allow a third gender
option for u.s citizens on their
passports the state department said
wednesday it has issued one it's the
first of its kind denoted with an x for
non-binary intersex and gender
non-conforming u.s citizens the
recipient is colorado resident dana
and the reason i pronounce it that way
is because the last name is spelled
z-z-y-y-m
i have doubts that uh this is the
original last name of this person
associate director of the intersex
campaign for equality and a client of
lambda legal
i almost burst into tears when i opened
the envelope pulled out my new passport
and saw the x stamped boldly under sex
i'm also ecstatic that other intersex
non-binary u.s citizens will soon be
able to apply for passports with the
correct gender marker it took six years
but to have an accurate passport one
that doesn't force me to identify as
male or female but recognizes i am
neither is liberating jijim said in a
statement
the agency is still preparing to make
the option widely available for
passports and other documents such as
the consular report of birth abroad so
it's not just for americans by the way
it's people who are green card holders
hold their us passport pretty much
anybody trying to get in the country
i want to reiterate on the occasion of
this passport issuance the state
department's commitment to promoting the
freedom dignity and equality of all
people including lgbt
lgbtqi plus persons said state
department spokesperson ned price in a
statement
it just uh the heroism the heroism
right we're just going to ignore the
objective reality or what id is supposed
to do so that you feel better about
yourself
the state department meanwhile is saying
that they're pursuing an end to
gender-based discrimination with
policies like this i mean not
gender-based discrimination in
afghanistan where women are literally
forced into bags and then into the
basement but gender discrimination like
you know for example being asked to say
whether you are biologically male or
female on a passport
president biden and secretary blinken
have made clear it is the policy of the
united states to pursue an end to
violence and discrimination on the basis
of gender of sexual orientation gender
identity or expression or sex
characteristics the department of state
is committed to promoting the freedom
the dignity and equality of all persons
including of course intersex persons
um so the very important stuff
now is this again is this the mark of a
civilization that is on the decline or
the mark of a civilization that is on
the mend and ready to grow
and if you're worried about people
getting married having babies a basic
basic thing that is necessary is
understanding that men and women exist
that sexual dichotomy exists in mammals
if you refuse to even acknowledge this
it makes it a lot more difficult to
convince people that it's important to
get together and have kids in stable
families
but we as a civilization have decided to
abandon that on behalf of higher falutin
ideals like can we make sure that no
carbon ever enters the atmosphere or at
least pretend to
right we have to make sure that that
gender fluidity is prized above the
survival of civilization right these are
these are things that matter
and to pretend that they're not in
conflict is very silly a civilization
that embraces fiction about the nature
of biological sex is a civilization that
is doomed to move away from reality
a civilization that rejects truth on
behalf of sensitivity is a civilization
that cannot exist for very long in the
real world reality always has its
revenge
it takes just one indicator really
interesting piece by suzy weiss over at
barry weiss's sub stack susie is barry's
sister
it's called first cum's love then comes
sterilization rachel diamond looks like
most of the moms the park slope cafe
where we meet she's wearing a green
t-shirt under a black corduroy jumper
sensible shoes carries a smart leather
bag she sips a four dollar iced chai
except the 31 year old isn't a mom and
she never will be you know diamond says
shirley i never expected to be the
poster child of sterilization
on the aspiring actress tick tock one
finds short funny videos about diamond's
job working the register at a cafe near
union square and updates on her rescue
pitbull rue who has anemia mixed in her
clips extolling her child-free life they
have titles like sterilization attempt
number three and being child free we do
know what we're missing
it's been five months since she had her
fallopian tubes cut not tied and she has
64 000 followers
growing up near hershey pennsylvania
diamond always assumed she'd have a
family of her own then came college at
arcadia university her political
awakening away from her conservative
roots and toward progressivism and a
therapist who she then found online a
few months after graduation who made her
realize that being spent as a child was
deeply traumatic and that made and that
it made her fear authority figures like
her father she decided she never wanted
to be one herself
never ever ever
looking back i never pretended my
american girl dolls were children they
were always my sister she said there
were little things showing that i wasn't
preparing myself for motherhood i think
for me it's as innate as saying i've
always wanted to be a mom
diamond is hardly an outlier says susie
weiss americans are making fewer babies
than we've made since we started keeping
track in the 1930s some women like
diamond are not just putting off
pregnancy they're eliminating the
possibility of it all together last year
the number of deaths exceeded that of
births in 25 states up from five the
year before the marriage rate is at an
all-time low 6.5 marriages per 1 000
people millennials are the first
generation where a majority are
unmarried about 56 they're also more
likely to live with their parents than
previous generations were in their 20s
and 30s they also aren't having sex the
number of young men ages 18 to 30 who
admit they've had no sex in the past
year tripled between 2008 and 2018.
cities like new york where secular young
americans flocked to build their lives
are increasingly childless in san
francisco there are more dogs than
children
any of this speak of a civilization in
growth mode
it used to be says susie weiss that
people wanted to make babies women
especially but also men
that was a healthy young person's
default position our existence depended
on it we wanted to do other things of
course the great post-feminist challenge
was how to have it all but for an
increasing number the question now isn't
how to have it all it's why do it at all
this psychological reversal didn't just
happen it took place inside the
hurricane of spiritual cultural
environmental forces swirling around us
but the message from this young cohort
is clear life is exhausting enough and
the world is broken and burning who
would want to bring new innocent life
into a criminally unequal society
situated on a planet with catastro
catastrophically rising sea levels
according to a new poll
39 percent of gen's ears are hesitant to
procreate for fear of the climate
apocalypse which is just insane guys i'm
sorry you're crazy
a nationally representative study of
adults in michigan found over a quarter
of adults are child free by choice
so basically we have decided that all
the hallmarks of being an adult all the
hallmarks of adjusting to reality and
building a civilization have been thrown
over in favor of a false pursuit of
gender identity and hedonism that that's
essentially the trade the trade is you
get to have a good time in the moment
and feel morally self-righteous as your
civilization dies by the way there are
other civilizations out there
so you can pretend that our civilization
dying is somehow a good thing because of
all of our historic excesses and all the
problems with our civilization just
understand there are other people out
there who are waiting to take over and
they are far far worse than our
civilization in virtually every way
but our civilization is now
socially suicidal and this has massive
consequences for the future
it means that the economy slows for
example it means there's no one there to
pay the bills it means
that
on foreign policy more people suffer
broadly speaking it means the growth
rates globally come to an end
it means that all the nice things that
you think are natural to life start to
collapse because when institutions that
created those things collapse so do the
things
virtually every westernized insta
every western country is now
experiencing massive drops in births
it's happening pretty much everywhere
according to pew research
in italy japan france belgium they're
among the nations that have reported
sudden drops in births about nine months
after the start of the pandemic compared
with the previous year
some worry that a baby bust will create
societal age imbalances and strain
healthcare and retirement systems while
also eventually stripping the economy of
young workers who tend to drive
innovation and growth
meanwhile
you can tell by the way that these are
these been dying civilizations for a
while considering how many kids are now
being born out of wedlock
one of the fundamental institutions of
society is marriage why because it in
civilization it civilizes men marriage
was designed to civilize men it was
designed to allow women to grow up in
intact to allow children to grow up in
intact homes and therefore have healthy
lives and then become productive members
of civilization themselves
marriage was a civilizing institution we
dumped it we decided that personal
self-fulfillment was much more important
than giving a kid an actual life with
two parents who care about them yes of
opposite sexes because a child does need
a mother and a child does need a father
right now the share of live births
outside marriage
in the united states
it's 70 in the black community it's 40
in the white community
it's true abroad
in france 60.4 of kids are born outside
marriage is as of 2018. in sweden it's
54.5 in denmark it's 54
if you think that has no relationship
with the number of people who are on
social assistance you're on your mind
if you think there's a healthy way for a
society grow you're crazy but that's
maybe this is a society with a death
wish
maybe this is a society that has decided
to sacrifice truth logic and decency in
favor of the notion that we are bad and
we deserve to go this way
right after all we are a scourge on the
earth
i think there is a strong reason why
when you look at the actual reproduction
rates in the united states they are
heavily associated with religion they
are striated by religion
right now the only people reproducing
above replacement rates in the united
states are people who are religious
period end of story
i mean i'm looking at the rates right
now the fertility rates in the united
states by religion among catholics
2.3 among mormons 3.4 these are above
replacement rates among jews 2.0 and
among orthodox uses like four
among protestants evangelical
protestants it's 2.3
and then among atheists 1.6 agnostics
1.3
that as as a society becomes more
secular as a society decides that future
that the future doesn't matter and
starts to undermine its own institutions
and starts to embrace fictional nonsense
on behalf of the subjective feelings of
a view the society begins to crumble
it also leads to absurdities like this
story from bbc news
quote i've had someone saying they would
rather kill me than hitler says 24 year
old jenny they said they would strangle
me with a belt if they were in a room
with me in hitler that was so bizarrely
violent just because i won't have sex
with trans women
jenny is a lesbian woman she says she is
only attracted to women who are
biologically female and have vaginas she
therefore only has sex and relationships
with women who are biologically female
jenny doesn't think this should be
controversial but not everyone agrees
she has been described as transphobic a
genital fetishist a pervert and a turf a
trans-exclusionary radical feminist
jenny who lives in london says there's a
common argument they try and use that
goes what if you met a woman in a bar
and she's really beautiful and you got
on really well and you went home and you
discovered she had a penis would you
just not be interested
yes because if someone seems sexually
attractive at first you can go off them
i just don't possess the capacity to be
sexually attracted to people who are
biologically male regardless of how they
identify
according to carolyn laubridge over at
bbc news
i became aware of this particular issue
after i wrote an article about sex lies
and legal consent several people got in
touch with me to say there was a huge
problem for lesbians who are being
pressured to accept the idea that a
penis can be a female sex organ i knew
this would be a hugely divisive subject
but i wanted to find out how widespread
the issue was ultimately it has been
difficult to determine the true scale of
the problem because there's been little
research on the topic only one survey to
my knowledge however those effective
have told me the pressure comes from a
minority of trans women as well as
activists who are not necessarily trans
themselves
so apparently this is now a major issue
among lesbians is that because of the
stupidity of suggesting
gender fluidity
lesbians are being told that they must
have sex with biological men
because if they don't have sex with
biological men this means that they are
apparently straight because some
biological men are women
and the illogic has no bounds there are
no limits to it none
and so as a civilization would we like
to die or we is a civilization going to
embrace basic truths that undergird
institutions that allow for growth
those are the choices before us it's
pretty obvious there's a whole group of
people in politics who are opting for
the former rather than latter that they
are opting for a civilization in decline
because at least we'll have a good time
on our way out because at least we will
feel justified morally in overturning
these structural oppressions of reality
because reality is full of structural
oppressions reality is full of
inequality reality is full of
difficulties so if we just ignore those
difficulties if we struck restructure
society around the idea that we can get
rid entirely of reality
then we can
put off the nightmares
we can put off having to adjust to
civilization to civilization
and then you know later if the
civilization falls apart you know i'm
pretty sure well you know we did our
best at least we did the moral thing
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang